so elden ring may be getting some
coliseum-based dlc and halo infinite's
co-op campaign is delayed
again
happy monday my fellow tarnished how
would you feel if eldon ring got some
additional content because it seems like
the game's lost coliseums in leondell
north limgrave and kalid could be signs
of future dlc these coliseums have been
locked in the game since launch and have
many players myself included scratching
their heads in confusion as to how to
open the doors and what lay in wait on
the other side and because it's a from
soft game i just assumed it was
something terrifying recently several
modders have finally found a way past
the locked doors to explore the
restricted locations videos like this
one from youtuber garden of eyes shows
that these buildings are far from empty
and may not have been just cut content
in fact each area's level of detail has
led many to speculate about what these
coliseums could be used for some guesses
across social media include challenges
special boss fights and a pvp arena let
me know what you're hoping for when it
comes to these coliseums and what you're
hoping for with elden ring dlc in
general
switching gears to halo infinite if
you're a fan who hasn't touched the game
because you're eagerly awaiting the day
you can experience it with your bestie
well i've got some bad news and you
might want to sit down both online and
split screen campaign co-op have been
delayed again this news comes via a new
halo infinite development update where
developer 343 industries broke down the
current high priority issues affecting
the game what fans can expect in season
2 of multiplayer and updates on co-op
and forge halo infinite head of creative
joseph staton writes in the blog post
that the non-linear wide-open sections
of the campaign present some big
challenges for split screen co-op and
while great progress has been made on
online co-op the reality is that it's
going to take more time to land a
high-quality full-featured four-player
network co-op experience in the massive
wide open world of halo infinite back in
december fans found a way to glitch
themselves into halo infinite co-op
shortly after the game's launch however
doing so risks corrupting the game's
save data and it's more than a little
buggy while co-op won't come with the
launch of season 2 officially titled
lone wolves 343 is aiming to release the
feature later in the season prior to the
launch of season 3. as for forge halo
infinite's custom map and game creation
tools those are currently on track to
arrive with season 3.
and in other delay news square enix in
luminous productions announced that
forspoken has been delayed to october
11th it was originally set to launch on
may 25th in a statement luminous said we
have made the decision to move the
release date of forspoken to october
11th our vision for this exciting new ip
is to deliver a game world and hero that
gamers across the world will want to
experience for years to come so getting
it right is extremely important to us to
that end during the next few months we
will focus all our efforts on polishing
the game and can't wait for you to
experience frey's journey this fall that
was a bummer i was really excited to
check this one out despite the mixed
previews from last year
um but this can only mean good things
for the game and maybe the next batch of
previews won't be as mixed
also on the bright side this means i get
more time for elden ring because lord
knows i will not be done with it by may
so this is good opens up my free time a
little bit let me know what you plan on
playing instead of four spoken if you
were going to play for spoken at all and
i'll see you tomorrow